after months of resistance from this
prime minister the government has
finally been dragged Kicking and
Screaming to extend the windfall tax
that labor had been calling for since
January
yet they still leave billions of pounds
on the table Yeah profits that are the
windfalls of War yeah
because they have failed to close a huge
loophole that they created that hands
out massive tax breaks to those oil and
gas giants for doing the things that
they were going to do anyway
for those wondering why some energy
Giants have paid no windfall tax in the
last quarter despite record profits and
eye-watering bills for consumers the
answer is the decisions that this prime
minister made when he was Chancellor
confirmed by the current Chancellor lets
the energy Giants off the hook once
again
Mr Speaker the government has announced
plans for energy bills next year but
Bill payers will still see prices go up
next spring leaving far too many people
wondering how they'll make ends meet for
every pound of windfall tax left on the
table
are faced with higher prices on their
bills and the Tories failure on energy
goes back much further
they closed down gas storage
blocked onshore wind and solar and
slashed support for home insulation now
today the chancellor says that he will
act on Energy Efficiency but I'm afraid
it's all far too late we called for the
insulation of two million homes a year
more than 12 months ago that could cut
bills by a thousand pounds not just for
one year but for every year to come and
they did nothing
insulation levels in 2021 were 20 times
lower than in 2010 because of their
neglect and now he proposes a package
but we have to wait until
2025 for them to ask why when people are
facing a bills crisis now you years and
years will have gone by while he sits
back millions of families could have
been helped and they have not been
[Applause]
and still they block Renewable Power
like onshore winds that could bring
energy bills down create good jobs in
all parts of the country and ensure that
Britain can lead the way in the
industries of the future
clean power is the right solution to the
energy price crisis but yet again the
conservatives have failed they have
failed to protect us from future shocks
failed to tackle the cost of living
crisis and fail to take the decisions in
our country's National interest
[Applause]